So the way this actually plays out,
it's easier to see in
the context of an example.
So let's go back to our
example from the banana game.
>> Okay.
>> So here is the U and
the U bar matrix from the banana game.
This is, actually I wrote
them backwards didn't I?
>> Doesn't matter.
>> So there's one player
who gets 0 no matter what.
>> Yep, that's the friend, that's Curly.
>> Yeah, that was Curly before.
And then there's one who
can get either 2, 0, or
4 depending on which
cell they end up playing.
And we said that the Nash
equilibria were these two corner
cases, the 2 and the 4.
So that gives us the purely
cooperative game,
which is the average of the payoffs for
the two players.
Which we're going to compute
the value of using maximax and
the purely competitive game from
the perspective of the U player.
So U- U bar / 2, which looks like this.
So we're going to try to
resolve the value by minimax.
Then there's the same quantity from
the perspective of the U bar player.
So it's just the negation of that one.
But we're going to compute the minimax
value for each of these different games.
So from the perspective of the U player,
what's the maxmax value and
the minimax value for these games?
So let's start with this one.
So what's the maximizing value?
>> It's the thing you're pointing at.
>> And that's the case where
U plays the second row.
And U bar plays the second column and
they get these payoffs.
>> Right we get four bananas.
>> Four bananas that we're
going to divide amongst us.
>> Sure.
>> So the minimax value, so
what's the score that the row player,
the U player the maximum score
that it could get for itself.
>> Minus one.
>> You get a minus one.
Right.
So how does it do that?
By picking this cell,
the top row because the top row if
you're trying to minimize my gains,
you're going to choose the left column.
If I choose the first row.
If I choose the second row,
you're going to choose the right column.
I'm going to do even worse.
>> Right.
>> So the best thing I can do
is choose the first row.
>> And I know that, so
I'm going to choose the first column.
>> Good.
And if we negate that,
we get a completely analogous analysis.
>> Right.
>> So, which column do you choose?
This or that, given that you're
trying to maximize your value.
It would be great if you
could choose a second column.
But I'm trying to minimize your value.
So I'm going to choose the first row
you can choose the second column.
So the safest thing you can do is to
the first column and I'm going to
need to choose the first row to keep you
from switching to go down to that too.
>> Right.
>> All right so
from the perspective of U,
the coco value is the sum of
these two things which is one.
And from U bar's perspective the coco
value is the sum of the min max game and
the max,
max game which is going to be three.
>> Right.
>> Now we have to define side payments.
So U's side payment, p,
is the coco value from U's perspective
minus the value that U gets
in the equilibrium which in this
case is zero but in general it's
whatever the utility is according
to U of the utility maximizing.
Joint action and side payments for
you bar are the coco value from
the perspective of Q bar minus the value
that U bar gets in the utility
maximizing joint action.
So, in this case that's one for you,
minus how much does U
get in that game 0.
So it's going to be 1.
Whereas, from p's perspective,
the coco value is 3 minus the payment
that U bar gets for playing the
utility-maximizing action, which is 4.
So we get minus 1.
>> And that makes sense because
it better be the case that
they are opposite and equal.
You know the transfer and
now you've answered my question who
gets to transfer money from the other.
>> That's right.
So,
this the U player is
going to get one and
the U bar player is going to give one
and that's the one banana exchange.